os enterros do Brasil não é
assim enterro nosso tem 350 pessoas no
enterro só 10 conhece o morto só os
outros é só curioso E foi o quê foi
facada foi mataram foi foi o
quê totalmente diferente as crianças não
tão nem aí para quem morru vão brincar
vamos para trás dos túmulos 31
32 33 aí botar o caixão dentro do buraco
sai o menino 31 salve todos o menino não
tem sensibilidade à crianças
é totalmente
diferente fiquei triste com
aquilo tinha um pingo de sensibilidade
as crianças e o enterro é da porta do
cemitério para dentro quem tá fora não
tá nem aí se tá tendo enterro não p est
enterrando a pessoa meio-dia do lado de
fora tá rolando churrasco é rapariga é
cabaré é mulher feita lotado de mulher e
ninguém tem sensibilidade